and click on afterwards in the book tv
series and topics list on the upper
right side of the page
tv is live today from chicago home of
the 30th annual chicago tribune printers
row lit fest we bring you several
authors today from the auditorium at
jones college prep high school including
books on illinois africa world war ii
and much more
first we'll kick off our live coverage
from the printer's row lit fest with
monique brinson demery author of finding
the dragon lady the mystery of vietnam's
madame new
good morning everybody
welcome to the 30th annual chicago
tribune printers row lit fest
i want to give special thank you to all
of our sponsors
the author's book will be sold in the
main lobby and signed outside of the
auditorium
book signing will immediately follow the
program
today's program will be broadcast live
on c-span 2's book tv
if there's time at the end for a q a
session
with the author we would ask if you'd
please use the microphone located here
on the stairwell to my left this way the
home home viewing audience can hear your
question
if you'd like to watch this program
again please note that our coverage will
re-air tonight at 11 pm central time
please keep the spirit of lit fest going
all year long with a subscription to
printers road journal
the tribune's premium book section
fiction series and membership program
this year we are also introducing a new
digital bookstore through our trib books
app please take one of our promo cards
for information about the app and access
to special book deals
before we begin today's program please
silence your cell phones you may turn
your camera flash off
we will allow you to take pictures
please post those pictures to twitter
instagram or facebook using
printersrow
gives me great pleasure to introduce to
you guys our moderator for today's
conversation eric banks mr banks thank
you thank you very much
welcome everyone it's very good to see
you here uh this morning and it's my
pleasure uh to welcome today uh monique
brinson dimmery uh the author of the
amazing book uh finding the dragon lady
the mystery of vietnam's madame new uh
which has recently been published by
public affairs books
dimmery holds a master's degree from
harvard university in east asian
regional studies and when she made
contact with madame new who was the uh
unofficial first lady of the south
vietnamese government um in 1999
2005 it was you were the first
journalist to interview her in almost 20
years and uh dimry is based in chicago
and we're happy to welcome you monique
well thank you for having me and thank
you for coming today it's such an
interesting book um i'm curious uh how
you first came to be interested in
writing a book about what i think to a
lot of people might be a somewhat
unlikely and unknown subject someone
who's uh known to scholars the history
of the vietnam war but probably not that
well known to so many other people how
did how would you become interested in
madame and you
well it started sort of by omission so
my my mother is french and my dad's
american and so vietnam was always
really hard to talk about in our in our
family it wasn't very clear to me um
what what had happened there and every
time i tried to ask the adults around me
it was too controversial to really talk
about so there was this nagging question
of okay what happened in vietnam and and
every time i looked at the books there
were the very gory pictures you know
that you've seen of vietnam or sort of
the napalm apocalypse now pictures and
then you know flip the page and here's
this beautiful
stylish um sort of very cosmopolitan
looking woman and they're calling her
the dragon lady or the best is the
diabolical sex dictators i mean what is
not to be interested in so um i started
digging around and
i actually just out of curiosity wanted
to read a book about this woman because
her life sounded interesting to me
putting the pieces together i would have
known that she
grew up during the french colonial
period and i thought
okay well someone's written maybe a
great historical bodice ripper about
this woman and there was nothing there
was really just these articles um from
the 60s that had been been written about
her and then um no biography no
historical fiction and what i noticed
was no obituary so that led me to think
um wow she's still alive it's somewhere
out there yeah she was a source of great
fascination for for for writers in the
early 60s who were reporting from
vietnam um and there there was this you
know very much of a built up image of
her in the united states but then after
um after she went into exile um
in rome and uh also and then later in to
paris she really does kind of disappear
from the record so you had a lot of of
uh sleuth work in in tracking her down i
did so i mentioned that there was no
obituary
there was no obituary for madame new but
what i did find right away was an
obituary for her parents her parents in
1986 they were living in georgetown um
they made their home there after he
resigned in protest from his um from his
daughter and and um son-in-law's
government so they had been living in
georgetown and in 1986 they were
murdered in their sleep by their only
son and i thought this is
this is real life this is this is
non-fiction so um so the mystery really
drew me in and that was the last time
madame new emerged from her sort of
self-imposed seclusion to say um you
know this is a family affair leave my
family alone
and at that time she was living in rome
but she was as you mentioned back and
forth between roman paris during those
years
um
did you start out possibly then the the
parents or the chunks um
did you start out thinking about writing
about their their lives perhaps and then
she became such an interesting figure to
you along the way well i certainly
thought there was something there i mean
their faces looking you know they're
they're like 90. i'm going to get the
names wrong because i don't have it in
front of me but they were like 90 and 86
or something when they were murdered and
they were murdered i read in their
pajamas and that to me seemed so
heartbreaking and sad so i started
digging into it and then what i found
was that these these lives these very
sort of sympathetic elderly couple
had in fact lived um
you know quite a life before that madame
news mother was known as the pearl of
the orient by the french and in the
french archives when i was sticking
around there i found all these
references to who she had slept with and
why and then she slept with the japanese
and i was like whoa this this woman and
then to sort of further confuse things
she was 14 when she had her her daughter
14 years old so i thought
there's really there's so much
contradiction here and she wasn't just
this sweet old lady she was a sweet old
lady who had slept around quite a bit
and you know but she had also had a
daughter at 14. so all of those
questions kind of led me to to pursue
them
it's a very aristocratic family we need
to probably take a step back and just
say exactly who madame knew was she was
the uh
her brother-in-law the the brother of
her husband uh became president of south
vietnam in
1956 or 55
54 he worse from the geneva
right right so yes madame new is sort of
the de facto first lady because the
president of south vietnam and there is
a few titles before that
uh prime minister premier but we'll just
for simplicity call him the president he
was a bachelor and um bachelor makes him
sound like he was going to vegas on the
weekends but he was really
um
very moral he slept on a hard wooden cot
he personally signed entry visas in and
out of the country staying up you know
late at night so there's these um
there's like this this kind of
very catholic austere man who needs a
first lady he needs someone to host the
parties and go to the orphanages and
host the flower shows and so madame knew
his younger brother's wife becomes this
woman and she's perfect for it she looks
great for the cameras she likes to be
out there and plus this finally gives
her sort of a voice and all of her life
i think madame knew had been looking for
this purpose i mean she was the second
child she'd been overlooked as a child i
think she always had a bit of a chip on
her shoulder um and so for her to be
handed this here you go be first lady be
the sort of official hostess she took it
and and really ran with it
yes and she
basically occupied this this role up
into up until uh 1963 uh when the uh the
government was uh upended by a coup and
her husband and her brother-in-law
president dieppe were both uh executed
that's right and and one more thing
madame wasn't just first lady she was
overwhelmingly elected you know by like
an unrealistic 99.9 percent of the
population to um to hold seats in in
congress in their um in their
legislature so by doing so she was still
the first lady hosting parties but she
could also pass laws and so madame knew
passed these what she called them family
and morality laws and some of them were
very well intended well i think perhaps
they were all well intended but um
south vietnamese women were not able to
open bank accounts they were not allowed
to own property and madam newton before
the laws before the laws and so madame
knew um recognized what her
husband and his brother did not was that
50 of the population was being just
ignored except by the communists who
were doing a great job of recruiting
women so madam new thought okay well
let's let's give these women some rights
and some power um and she did and and um
sort of took it upon herself to be the
voice of the women but she wasn't like
most vietnamese women she
she came from
a very aristocratic family they spoke
french at the dinner table
so for her to suddenly declare herself
the voice of the vietnamese woman was a
little presumptuous and she couldn't she
uh was unable to write in in vietnamese
is that correct or
she didn't write i mean she she could um
but she her she expressed herself most
fluently in in french which is what of
course she studied in school and and
what they spoke at home um so the other
laws that she passed were a little
ridiculous i mean thinking about them in
context it seems to make sense um
vietnam was a country at war and the
north vietnamese the communists were
doing a very good job of saying okay
this is a war we have to treat it
seriously and madame knew was a little
worried saigon was becoming like a party
i mean there were pizza stands and um
you know girly bars and all of that
stuff that was already starting in the
in the 50s and madame news said no we
have to be we have to take this
seriously so she outlawed
dancing along with prostitution she
outlawed hand-holding and kissing she
outlawned outlawed underwire bras but
she wore them
so she had these sort of um
this moral
like high horse and then the best was
her sister um had been married off young
like madame new head and her this was
her older sister and she was married to
a guy who worked for the no government
the zm government and
he
they fell out of love as i guess you
know happened and she fell in love
instead with a french guy he was a big
game hunter and he um and madame knew
thought this is you can't leave a good
upstanding vietnamese guy for a french
guy this is really looking bad this is
looking sort of colonial um so when her
sister tried to divorce her husband
madam new outlawed divorce and the story
goes you know there's no records of this
but the story goes that madam new sister
slashed her wrists and goes running
through the palace and madame knew locks
her up in a hospital and it takes their
own mother to come back to saigon to
break out the daughter
who then goes to
um the united states and marries the
french guy anyways yeah
and are these uh this is the they're
still alive correct i believe so i i've
tried she lives in north carolina is
that correct i've tried to to reach out
to her with letters um
but i they've been unanswered so her her
husband has published a couple memoirs
of his time um and they've been
published by a small press in canada or
perhaps self-published
quite interesting it's well that's one
of the things that's remarkable about
your book and about her story and and i
should point out you you mention
you know her her her look she's a
a really striking figure it's hard to
characterize her but you know this this
image on the cover really says it all
you probably you all probably can't see
it from your from the distance but
she's uh she knows how to handle a
pistol
so and especially with the kind of sort
of beehive haircut it's it's it's a nice
look um she did have a fashion thing so
yeah the the audi was what the women
wore and it has a high collar a mandarin
collar and madame new was one of the
first to say you know
show if you got it flaunt it and so she
so she cut the neck down so that you
could see kind of her collarbone and um
at the time this was like really risque
and so the president her brother-in-law
says you know don't you think that's a
little too flashy and she said something
like it's not your neck that's sticking
out it's mine so shut up that's a great
line now what i was what i start what i
was going to say though is it's it's
fascinating not just from a geopolitical
standpoint and and from a
historical standpoint but it really is a
family saga as well um and one of also
one also where you see someone who was
able to um
whatever we think about her and we could
we can come back to that in a little bit
had just an incredible amount of
gumption um she managed to
uh
you know create herself and and to
really to direct her own idea of what
her public image would be with within
our you know with an iron will um and
and i think that's really fascinating
about her
and it seems like when you made contact
with her you know much advanced years
many years later um that that sense of
herself was was still very very much
intact
i love the word gumption i think that's
a great description
uh and yes madame knew was going to tell
her own story so when i did find madame
knew she was in her early 80s and she
sort of said to me
uh this is great you're the you're the
angel that god sent me we're going to do
my memoirs you're going to get me bill
clinton's book deal it's going to be
great and i was like
all right you know but i really wanted
to hear what she had to say but she had
a very specific way of seeing her past
which is understandable perhaps we all
revise history our own way but to madame
knew she was vietnam was the center of
the universe and she was sort of the
the thing everything revolved around so
she she was very
much at the center of her story
but then again it was also
understandable i mean her husband and
brother-in-law were killed you know with
the sanction of the americans and she
had gone through this this life that had
been
you know quite quite hard and so i think
to make sense of it she really turned to
religion and mysticism and that was the
only way that she could really make
sense of things was kind of
biblically ordained it was a mix of a
kind of joan of arc idea crossed with i
don't know what else uh this
survivor's story um
she uh
how did she come to
do you think it's a for really just the
force of her personality gave her the
the presence that she had in the
government and so much so i mean the
americans thought that she was really
the problem um
behind the problems that that were very
clear um with with in the south
vietnamese government that she had that
she was the one pulling the strings um
and and i think the way that you write
about her she does you know she does
come across as someone who had an
unbelievable amount of influence over
what
what her brother-in-law did um do you
think that's just a you know force of
her personality you write about for
example when she was taken prisoner of
war in 1946 um by the by the communists
uh by the vietnam army um
and and that this figure emerges from
that who who is is so strong um
is that your sense of it or do you think
her role has been somewhat overrated in
in the government
i think it's actually a little bit of
both if that's possible so yeah madame
new had this she has this story of when
she was taken by the communists and and
she's carrying her infant daughter you
know walking across this bridge and
bullets are flying and she emerges
unscathed and for her she was like
oh yeah i got it all i got to do is like
you know be brave and that message that
sort of all you know in the face of your
enemy just just stare him down um and
stand strong no matter what you do don't
back down that was kind of her her motto
um
and i think she tried to pass that on to
the brothers there was one point when
president dm was negotiating there had
been a coup attempt and he was
negotiating to open up his government
and madame new thought that was just
awful that he would
dare to
share power and all that stuff so she
you know convinced him to stand firm so
in some ways yes she had
this power to
convince the brothers that they didn't
need to open up their government they
needed to lock all the doors you know
keep it even more insular but um but i
think the other thing was that just the
appearance that it looked like the men
were following what she said
kennedy said something like um she looks
like she's leading the men around by her
apron strings so they were just sort of
following it in her wake and i think
that was just as dangerous as any real
power to make it they were sort of
emasculated by her and that was
kennedy's biggest fear was that it would
look like america was following this
little lady around and that was
not gonna fly
yeah and her so much of her her
criticism of of uh well i should put it
this way
so much of her reaction to what was
taking place in vietnam it's
modernization it's it's it's
neocolonialization if you want to call
it that um certainly the westernization
that uh started to appear in in south
vietnam in
in the late 50s and early 60s that she
rallied against
was very much of a criticism of america
it put her very much i mean because so
much of that was made possible by the
influx of foreign policy money from the
united states
which put her very quickly i think on
the opposite side of the intentions of
the
government the united states well she
was happy for the money i mean let's be
clear
that was how they were funding the fight
but um but what they wanted was
the money but then you know stay out of
our business let us let us run our
government and the united states
obviously wanted strings attached to
that money um and when things weren't
going the right way um for example the
united states tried to send in ground
troops a lot earlier but you know the
brothers said absolutely not you know we
can't
these have to be advisors only
and it wasn't until the
much later that that obviously the
vietnam war escalated into what it
became
there were several coup attempts
against the government beginning in 1960
i believe um there's one famous um
assault where a couple of um
a couple of airmen flew and bombed the
palace and and she narrowly survived
right so there was a direct hit on
madame news bedroom some rogue south
vietnamese air force pirate pilot was
was tired of this sort of
bossy lady pushy lady um one of the
vietnamese i i talked to said she was
she was talk too big she just she was
too much
so one of these south vietnamese air
force pilots was upset about it and did
a direct hit of her
suite and so there was this gaping hole
madame new fell through she said three
stories you know again this is another
one of her sort of survival um if she
survived it
she was magical but she she hurt her arm
but one of the children's nannies was
killed but otherwise no one
no one in the family was hurt
and then finally the the protests
against the government began to escalate
um in 62 and 63. um and there are uh the
for the first time these uh very strong
um confrontations with the buddhists in
um in in vietnam which you described
very well um
why don't you tell us about how those
those protests started and what
i think this is really when madame knew
seals her place as a a bad figure in
history it's around the buddhist
protests if you'll remember um there
were the famous pictures of the buddhist
monks uh burning themselves in uh
traffic stops i think there were seven
who committed suicide that way as a way
of protesting against the government
right so
it started with a law that had been on
the books since colonial times no flag
was allowed to fly higher than the state
flag but of course nobody really paid
attention to that there had just been a
big catholic festival and white and gold
flags had been flying all over um and so
for the buddha's birthday sometime in
may
uh
one of the brothers went so there's ziem
who is the president his brother madame
knew's husband who was kind of he was
the head of the secret police he was
also in charge of all the politics i
mean he was kind of the guy who did the
dirty deeds and there were a few other
brothers one of who was the archbishop
of hue which is the
city in central vietnam and when he was
coming into town one morning he noticed
that buddha's flag was flying too high
and so he ordered people to take it down
and there was this kind of
backlash by the buddhists of how why are
you enforcing this really random law now
and instead of backing down and saying
you're right you know we're making sort
of a mess out of this um
the nose cracked down and there was
suddenly there was um
a protest by the buddhists and people
started firing on them and people were
killed and so then instead of saying
we're sorry things that got out of hand
the no family blamed the communists and
they said all the communists were
shooting at the buddhists well no they
weren't
so um so it quickly turned into a mess
and basically the
buddhist repression was
less
i mean less repression in the way that
we think of now than more of a vehicle
for every grievance you could think of
because no one had been allowed to say
anything against this family so
but every 90 of the country was buddhist
so everyone could sort of identify with
this wow you're putting down these
people so everybody jumped onto this
bandwagon and
elderly monks were um were
self-immolating which means that they
were letting themselves on fire and when
madame knew saw it she sounds like marie
antoinette you know she says
great let's clap our hands and have a
barbecue i mean the most cruel response
you could have to a an old buddhist monk
lighting himself on fire and that just
spread like wildfire around the world
people couldn't believe that she could
be so callous now in madame news
perspective was well the buddhists have
been intoxicated which doesn't mean
drunk it means poisoned and they had
been intoxicated by communism and they
they were a very loose knit
association organization there were no
sort of strict rules coming in and
coming out so madame new was pretty sure
they were
had had already been infiltrated by
communists and it turns out actually
that by 1968 the united states even
agreed yes they had been
they had been used as a cover by by
communists but in 1963 that was such a
shocking thing to say and then to be so
like casual about suicide um it was
unforgivable yeah it's it's never i
don't think it's ever a good tactic for
a uh leader who's support who's
uh dependent on uh foreign aid to uh
castigate buddhist monks
protesting in the name of religious
freedom and whatever else um and that
and that is really when i think at that
point that
the uh
the u.s government
knows that it has a problem on its hands
in it and it
tacitly supports the coup that will come
correct um
in august president kennedy okays a
change in government and
the new ambassador that sent over to
saigon goes with the understanding that
he is there to go look for alternatives
to zm and this family that's been in
power now for nine years um
and it takes some there are some false
starts um but you know some real
alternatives have finally been
identified and the brothers are are
killed um november 1st 1963 which as
many of you know that's just a few weeks
before kennedy himself was assassinated
so madame new is a conspiracy figure in
some of these um who killed kennedy
questions people must think it has
something to do with madame new but i
can assure you it it doesn't um but it
was terrible terrible timing um
and so
kennedy seemed really shocked that the
brothers had been killed
by all accounts he he gets up when he
hears the news and he's visibly shaken
and can't believe that they've actually
killed the brothers but you know he was
the one who sort of gave the okay to go
ahead and topple this allied country
this friendly regime and um and
overthrow them so for him to think that
they could have gotten out any other way
is a little little naive
now
at that time she was on a on a tour of
the united states and she believed that
if uh that if she came to the united
states and convinced people that there
was a grave threat um if if our
government was not supported that
communists would would would topple
south vietnam pretty quickly and so she
came to the united states on a on a
speaking tour and um
and quite a spectacular tour she went to
a lot of colleges did a lot of
television um in a day that was probably
a lot harder to
at a time it was a lot harder to do that
than it probably is today i think um
what was her what was her reception like
when she came to the united states it
was very mixed so um as you say she came
to the united states because she had
been asked to leave vietnam by now the
buddhist thing had
really escalated and the united states
thought the only thing we're gonna the
only way we're gonna tamp this down and
restore any order is if madame knew just
leaves so this had been something that
um zm and his brother had had not been
willing to do but finally they say okay
madame knew you got to go you got to get
out of vietnam you got to shut up
basically and so where does she go she
comes right to the united states and
goes on this like
press relations tour and she doesn't
understand the difference she's invited
to come speak at harvard at columbia at
georgetown
and she's also invited by
you know meet the press and all of these
press organizations and she doesn't
understand why she feels like the
government hasn't rolled out the red
carpet for her i mean wasn't she invited
and she just doesn't get this separation
between
the press and the government because in
her country of course like the
government
the breast can only say what the
government wants them to say so for her
it was really um
totally befuddling to the end of her
days i can't understand why they invited
me to come and then said go home why
didn't they want me here so she goes um
she goes to new york she goes to
washington dc she comes to chicago she
stays in the blackstone hotel and
one of my favorite moments of the trip
is she goes to dallas and there's a
ranch there and
and she gets invited to go shooting so
her so her daughter dresses up in like
western gear and apparently has like her
first kind of teenage romance with a a
texas guy
um
and her reception that madame new gets
well her mother was very worried about
madame new's visit to the united states
so she pulls a state department guy
aside and has a meeting and says you
know madame new really shouldn't come
here i've warned all the vietnamese to
throw tomatoes at her and if they see
her to run run her over with their car
this is her mother um she does get
tomatoes soon at her she gets eggs
thrown at her but she also gets standing
ovations from fordham from from
georgetown from a lot of um catholic
education i was going to say that's i
mean she really mapped out the catholic
uh college and university itinerary as
part of her part of her tour and was she
presented at that point as this i mean
her catholicism was also was you know
was a very important part of her
political ideology or if you want to
call it that um
was she seen in that light in in in 1963
in the united states i mean i assume
that to the extent that she was hitting
you know
places like fordham and georgetown that
that was they were very much
self-conscious of that um
was that part of her reception as well i
i do think so and part of the political
philosophy of the south vietnamese
government was based on something called
personalism which is this
philosophy that started in france in the
20s and it was a catholic philosophy it
was supposed to be an alternative to
pure capitalism and communism so it was
kind of this third way and so that
really was a cornerstone of their of
their government no one could quite
understand how that translated to south
vietnam
and so that was really
the problem was in the marketing um but
the the regime had bought all this
property outside of rome
and
property in post-war rome is pretty
inexpensive and so they bought up large
tracts of land with the idea that then
they would send these south vietnamese
functionaries over to rome to go get
indoctrinated in their version of
personalism and then and then come back
to south vietnam so that didn't work out
so well for them but it was a place that
madame knew after her family was fell
from power she could go back to that
land outside of rome which was now very
valuable and sell it off piece by piece
to survive no but i was always curious
about that
in her relationships with uh with with
kennedy and the fact that he disliked
her so much and i was more interested in
how the catholicism
worked into that i you would almost
think that there might be some kind of
um you know sense of closeness between
her and kennedy that was obviously not
there her
if anyone the person who would who had
the um uh
fonda's thoughts about her would have
been lbj
that's right madame knew was convinced
he was flirting with her i think he
might have flirted with everyone
but the the connections between the goal
family in saigon and the kennedy family
in washington it's really
and the kennedy family in washington
it's really
it's uncanny on paper they look like
they should have gotten along great
catholic families both governments run
by a lot of family members um
and and very anti-communist so they
should have really gotten along well but
as it turned out they didn't and
jacqueline kennedy was a real critic of
madame news she thought madame knew was
just
sort of pushy
she called her um
she called her everything that jack
found unattractive and you know when
sort of pressed you know she she boasted
about her own marriage to president
kennedy saying oh they have this asiatic
marriage which i don't know it's a
direct quote that's a direct quote it's
an asiatic
marriage so what is that who knows but
sort of submissive and madame knew was
anything but submissive so um the worst
that jackie could say about her was that
she was probably a lesbian
that's interesting i mean you talk in
the book also about the the kind of idea
of the of the dragon lady it's a
stereotype that has been applied to you
know any number of of powerful uh women
from
asian countries um and particularly um
in in in government from the you know
beginning of the 20th century to the end
of the 20th century
absolutely so there's madame shanghai
sheck was the dragon lady madame mao was
the dragon lady and then you see her in
every kind of hollywood um bad guy movie
starting you know starring the the
powerful sly conniving asian woman
or she's the very submissive kind of
geisha girl so there's really these
two ways that asian women have been
portrayed
and so
when women rise to a certain level of
politics they certainly get shoved into
one of these two very neat categories
um yeah i mean we even had chicago's own
tokyo rose that's right
was in chicago yeah
the one i mean that when when when i was
trying to kind of reckon with it with
this very complex figure um and you you
try and present her in all her
complexity which i which i think is is
is wonderful
i kept thinking also about imelda marcos
um who doesn't come up in the book uh
but it strikes me as a kind of counter
model she certainly wasn't a figure like
that no she wasn't and i just heard that
there's a broadway play in new york or
an off-broadway play in new york
disco themed about imelda marcos i i
thought it was called kinky kinky boots
the thousand shoes um so
it's called here lies love and i think
madame knew would be a great character
for that guy's next musical um
but
imal de marcos was
was flashy and and flamboyant and did
not go quietly
either has
has anyone been interested in making a
film about her life um if i may ask
not that i know of okay so if there's
anyone out there you know taking offers
what was she like when you
i mean you've portrayed this very well
in the book but but tell us a little bit
about what she was like when you finally
did make contact
she she wasn't exactly advertising where
she lived in paris she wasn't really
she had avoided paris for some time
because she could have been extradited
correct yes so it had rented the rented
the apartment is that correct they the
apartment that they owned in paris and
madame new told me she was given the
apartment she said it was an anonymous
gift and she always
implied to me that it had been given to
her by the american government because
they felt bad for knocking off her
husband and brother-in-law and she had
no other place to go she tried to come
to the united states but her visa was
denied so they needed to keep her in a
safe place and so when she would leave
paris she would rent out that apartment
and sort of get the extra cash from it
but that was where i found her so
i've my vietnamese is really bad but
every from now and then i'll go online
and try to sort of dictionary decipher
my way through a little article and i'd
found this article written in the early
2000s by a guy who claimed to have
interviewed madame new and she was on
the i don't know 12th floor of this
building and and that sort of rang a
bell to me so i thought back to my notes
and i thought oh yeah um
i i see here that she wrote a letter to
claire booth loose from this address
close to the eiffel tower i'll i'll go
there and see if i can i don't know find
her so this is when i thought there was
no way i'd ever get her to talk to me
and this was around 2005 it was around
2005. so turns out i go to this address
it's it's only eight stories high so i
think my vietnamese it's really bad i
totally mistranslated this
and i look and then i sort of look
around paris and i realize all of the
buildings in paris are in fact really
low and if i'm looking for a 12-story
building i i won't have to go very far
it's like washington dc there's just
there there are
limits on how high buildings can be
built and so it really sticks out if
it's a tall building it does and so i
started walking around paris
literally knocking on doors of any
building that was high enough and
finally i got to one and the concierge
said i said oh does an older vietnamese
woman live here and i wasn't sure if she
what name she was going by and any of
that and she said oh no she doesn't live
here she lives next door so
that was how i i found her and i um was
writing her letters and asking her to
let me tell her story trying to pitch it
as sort of like a let you know
let me sort of do this in a scholarly
way
but what ended up happening was the most
unscholarly thing possible we connected
um in a way
because um the the day that she called
me for the first time i had written i
don't know maybe 10 letters at this
point um was the day that i found out
that i was pregnant so i i i get this
phone call and the woman says this is
madame new and i've just found out that
i'm pregnant with our first son and so
automatically my sort of relationship
with her
going through the birth of of my son was
this almost maternal sort of
grandmotherly thing i think we told her
we told our families you know that we
were expecting but like before i told
many of my friends i told this woman on
the phone who immediately changed her
attitude towards me it was suddenly like
oh i've been there let me tell you my
experience and we could really connect
in a way that was so
personal and i think unthreatening for
her because suddenly i was this
girl who needed help and she had had
four four children so she could tell me
everything there was to know
and then uh and then you developed this
relationship over a number of years and
very very much of a game of sort of cat
and mouse
um how long did it take for her to
really to
start to talk to you about the about the
the memoir that she was
hopefully going to tell you about she
started talking about the memoir almost
right away but it was clear to me that
this memoir was never going to be
produced i mean she'd been talking about
the memoir in 1963 she'd mentioned it to
the saturday evening post and so then i
remember one time we're talking she's
like i mean there are pages everywhere
even under my sofa and i thought oh gosh
we're never gonna get this um but they
did exist and before she passed away she
was she was ill for a long time and
before she passed away she really
decided okay i've got to get this done
this is my last chance to get my side of
the story heard and so she sent
them to me all you know 400 pages
of why
why she was the center of the universe
we want to
take questions your questions if um if
you have any but i just want to ask you
a couple of things before we before we
do that um
you're writing about a period that's
that's been receding in the american
imagination for some time after being so
you know so important um
how has the book been received i i think
when we were talking earlier you
mentioned that
there
you know you get a lot of feedback i
think from from from vietnam veterans
people are very interested in and invest
in the history of
south vietnam and want to know more
about that um
what has that been like well there's
really been two different responses and
um and the veterans community has been
wonderful and
curious about my work and in some sense
the harshest critics i mean i'm i'm so
i'm young and i wasn't there and i don't
have that experience and so i really do
respect the people who had the first
hand experience there um but they often
wonder why would why would you ever go
digging into this woman she was terrible
and she should just be left as it is she
hurt so many people and um made vietnam
which was already a problem so much
worse why would you ever go digging
around in that and my answer to that is
simply because she was a fascinating
exploration of what
went wrong with our involvement in south
vietnam and she sort of personalizes the
history in a way that people of my
generation
when i was in eighth grade we couldn't
even talk about the vietnam war yet in
school because it wasn't okay i mean it
was too controversial so i think now
there's more education about it but i
think it's still a really hard conflict
to
streamline and and get people
talking about so if this is one way to
do that
matamu is a very polarizing figure and
i think
i think needs to be explored in
warts and all
right and did your feel did your
personal feelings for her
change over time did it affect the way
that you saw her i don't know if
you started the project having a sense
of hers being a sort of a black and
white figure um uh politically and
historically i don't know how um whether
you did begin you know from that kind of
a position but did
did she become much more personalized as
you were in the process of working on
the book well certainly when i started i
thought oh this is a woman who's been
stereotyped and it's sexist and i was
going to rescue her and all this stuff
but she really
didn't need to be rescued
she she she was good and bad she was
complicated and so i think that my you
know initial i'm gonna
i'm gonna do this world of great service
was quickly changed when i started
learning all the facts um but i have
the utmost respect for her i mean she
was a strong woman in a time and place
that it was not okay to be a strong
woman and i really think that
she
embodied a lot of the conflicts that
women face when they are trying to
be ambitious in a place that won't won't
let them express themselves um you know
and tries to put them down so
i have a lot of respect for her and and
not only her
she had not only strong detractors who
who were women um in the early 60s but
most most the the couple people who
really
thought that she was a much more complex
person and wanted to write about her and
all that complexity were also we're also
women i mean you talk about margaret
higgins for example margarite higgins
and claire booth loose
they were they were big advocates of of
madame new you're right yeah it's
interesting i mean i think that we're
we're living at a time that we we we see
more interesting biographies written of
women political figures um and
particularly from from asia than than
than we've seen there was a really
interesting biography last year of um
um
written by the woman who wrote uh
yeah and uh that's you know it seems
like there's there's a different
generation of women who have come of age
after after the victories of feminism um
offering very interesting perspectives
that would not have been available i
think uh you know 30 and 40 years ago so
that's that's wonderful and i i think
it's a terrific book um just very happy
to
have been able to uh to read it and
let's see does anyone have any questions
in the audience
i think there's a we have a mic if
um
yes hi
um you've talked um a little bit about
how madame news
recollections might have been colored by
the trauma that she experienced and i
wondered how you dealt with
the unreliability of this source um
while you were working on this project
that's a great question so um madame new
was an unreliable narrator and i
in writing my book i chose
sort of the unorthodox path of putting
myself in the book because i wanted to
be
someone who could see both sides i mean
i did the research in the archives in
france i did the research into the
materials here in the united states and
i think there are no real objective
views of madame new that what was
written about her in the 60s was also
slanted by the
mostly white male reporters who were
writing about her
and so
from both of these sides i had to kind
of navigate okay
what is what is true what is false and
and in her memoirs that she wrote where
she's the center of the universe
obviously that wasn't going to be much
help to me but what was was finding out
what kind of shoes she was wearing sort
of the little details that were
factual that i wasn't going to get any
place else
but you're right that was a really
tricky thing and i tried to be as honest
as i can in the book about
walking that fine line between believing
what she says and also making sure it's
factually correct
the photographs i mean i mentioned this
earlier really really quite incredible
and the and um and i noticed that a
couple of them came from her own
collection is that
did she give you those photographs so
those were part of the memoir to be um
published for clinton okay yeah okay
uh sir do you have a question yes thank
you first off eric and monique thanks a
lot for a very great program
uh my question though i'm i'm curious
about what you think how the press did
the u.s press because you mentioned the
vietnamese press how it was under the
thumb of the vietnamese government how
much
better did the american press do because
you must have read a lot of articles and
watched a lot of news clips you know the
the us media did they build her up or
demonize her or trivialize her or you
know how did the u.s press do that's
such a good question um
the u.s press when you know i think if
you read the accounts of albert stam and
and sheehan and malcolm brown who were
there
in those early days um they they tend to
have really believed that the united
states was doing the right thing by
being in vietnam this was a country that
needed to be saved that the dominoes
were very real they were really falling
and um and so they were really
sort of patriotically behind the united
states involvement in south vietnam um
but because of that madame new and her
family were really a stumbling block i
mean they were screwing things up right
and left and these reporters could see
it and no one else was talking about it
and so they were
advocates for
i don't want to say they were advocates
for regime change but they were
advocates for
getting america more involved in south
vietnam reporting the facts as they saw
them which
was hard to do in that in that context
i don't think that they i don't think
they built madame new up i i really
don't think that they liked her very
much
and
should point out too that she read them
religiously and there's there's a point
in the in in the book where you tell her
that david halverstem has just been
killed in a car accident he was he was
in a car accident in 2008 or something
like that and you you tell her that you
break that news to her and she's
actually seems kind of kind of saddened
by it yeah so as if she had been it was
a personal friend of her someone she'd
known well
he he said something about her like she
was the only one in the family who knew
how to do a parade you know she raised
her hand like mussolini you know she he
said these things that in any other
reading would be um
not compliments but she was sort of like
oh i remember him he was a good reporter
and he always told the truth
on that note i think we're about out of
time i want to thank you very much and
please uh
outside the books are for sale we hope
you'll pick up a copy thank you
all right thank you everybody for
attending thanks again to uh mr banks
and miss demery copies of finding the
dragon lady are on sale now out in the
main auditorium and miss demery will be
signing books just outside of the
auditorium thanks everyone enjoy the lit
fest
yes
[Music]
[Music]
yeah well i drink mine
that was monique brinson demery talking
about the search for vietnam's madame
new we'll be back with more shortly
oh
[Music]